as algeria continues to battle these
raging wildfires and all that operation
is underway on the ground and from the
skies
we are watching the fire to try to
prevent it from spreading further but it
seems to be impossible and now reached
our zone
emergency crews and villagers are doing
everything they can with what little
they have
using buckets of water hoses and
branches the desperation is clear as
people race to save more homes from
burning to the ground and prevent
further loss of life
people have died schools and houses have
burned down the villagers have left
their homes to take refuge in communal
halls
the hardest hit area is a mountainous
region of kabil east of the algerian
capital as many as 18 provinces in total
are affected
there's a lot of damage some have lost
their homes lots of things nature will
not recover soon given that the people
here live off their olive groves this is
only the beginning of the disaster
the government has deployed the army but
dozens of soldiers were among those who
died during a rescue operation and the
government is now calling for
international help
the european union is lending its planes
that were used to battle the wildfires
in greece
algeria's prime minister has visited
dizzy uzu one of the affected regions
announcing the president's plans to
compensate those who have been affected
as the country enters three days of
national mourning
post-disaster relief operations are
already underway with residents teaming
up with charity organizations to collect
necessities for those that are injured
and the hundreds of families left
homeless
we responded to an announcement asking
to collect donations and medicines and
that's what we did but i make here
another urgent announcement to all
pharmacies in algeria we need medicine
algeria is just one of several nations
battling wildfires as record-breaking
temperatures spark widespread
devastation
but authorities here believe many of the
flames were deliberately lit
jillian wolf al jazeera
joining us from the province of tizi uzu
is maher mazahi he's a journalist who's
been covering these forest fires thanks
for joining us maher we've seen in
julian's report those devastating scenes
but there really is a sense of community
in fighting these fires isn't there
yeah absolutely today i went to the
center of tzuyu where there was a sort
of makeshift distribution center set up
where donations of humanitarian aid
streamed in from all corners of the
country
anything from bottles of water to baby
diapers to milk to juice and these were
duly loaded into trucks and they've been
sent to the different villages uh in the
province of tzuyu which have been hit
hardest by these wildfires
and
what more can you tell us about how the
public is reacting to the government or
the lack of help from government
authorities
yeah there's a lot of desperation a lot
of anger and a lot of sadness i'm not
sure if you can see behind me but
there's uh massive wildfires just down
in this in this little valley and behind
me there's sorry in front of me there's
a road where people are evacuating their
homes because these wildfires are
spreading so rapidly it is dry there are
very high winds i'm not sure if you can
hear them upwards of 20 kilometers per
hour and people are really desperate to
find a solution but unfortunately they
feel like the government has been
ill-equipped to deal with such solutions
and uh they're all waiting uh funnily
enough i just spoke to uh some
inhabitants they're waiting for the the
french aircrafts that are supposed to be
coming and one of them joked and he said
perhaps he lost his airport uh sorry he
lost his passport so uh so it's it's a
desperate situation at least they can
find some sense of humor in that
desperate situation there
what how do you see the next few days or
weeks unfolding
i i see a bunch of trucks here of young
men and young women with shovels um
water tanks uh dirt anything they can to
put out these fires and i suspect that
they'll continue that fight for the next
three or four days uh those two
airplanes that the french government are
sending over will also be here helping
to put out those fires those have a
capacity of 6 000 liters that they can
mix with retardant and salt water to
help put out those fires the algerian
military have also put
some helicopters at uh the population's
disposal those have a capacity of 1000
meters so it's just going to be
fighting these fires as much as possible
unfortunately for the rest of the week
temperatures will continue to be in the
40s with zero percent of zero chance of
precipitation so it's not looking good
yeah well they've actually been
described as the most destructive fires
or some of the most destructive fires in
the country's history
what is your experience on the ground
what are you actually seeing
i've never seen anything like this there
are really whole valleys whole swaths of
land that are completely
crisp they're they're carbonated i've
never seen anything like this i've never
heard of wildfires uh causing 70 deaths
however wildfires do happen on a yearly
basis in algeria that is not new but
never to this destruction and i think
that is what people find suspicious and
that is i think why even the government
hinted at arson however the government
to date so far has not presented any
evidence for those claims they have
arrested three people in the province of
media and one person in the province of
anaba
thank you for your comprehensive report
there maher mazahi reporting for us live
there